noch mal zu ihnen ich habe eine Frage
ich würde zwei ihrer Thesen sozusagen
einfach prinzipiell anzweifeln und sie
sagen was der Putin der sagt das muss
man nicht ernst nehmen natürlich muss
man das ernst nehmen dieser Mann hat die
Ukraine angegriffen ich habe nicht von
der ernst nehmen wir schon sie sagen zu
mir egal was der sagt aber wir müssen
andere Bemühungen das nicht anders sagt
oder so kommt nicht drauf an würde ich
sehr im Zweifel ziehen das zweite ist
sie sagen das lohnt sich für den nicht
man dieser Mann hat 20% der ukrainischen
Territoriums jetzt sich so mal unter der
Nagel gerissen in den letzten Jahren das
ist Wirtschaftskraft um dies da auch
geht da geht's auch um demografische
Themen wenn man da mal tiefer eintaucht
ja weil Demographie eine älter werdende
Gesellschaft hat Putin auch in Russland
da geht zum ganz ganz viele Dinge auf
ganz vielen verschiedenen Ebenen und die
These dass ich dieser Krieg für ihn
nicht lohnt die würde ich so wirklich
machen
ich glaube schon wenn ich nur noch
Freunde habe in Nordkorea viel mehr ist
da nicht mehr übrig ist man schon
ziemlich isoliert er kriegt keine
westliche Technologie also ich würde das
nicht schön reden
war für ihn gar nicht
bei dem G20 Gipfel das dann nun keine
großartigen Erklärung rauskommen die
einen zufriedenstellen als Papier
beeinflusst die Welt jetzt nicht so aber
wie sie starten auf stellen ob das
Papier ist oder nicht natürlich auch ein
bisschen Putin wir müssen auch ein
bisschen lernen wir 82 Millionen
Deutsche wir haben es mit einer
Milliarde und mehr Innern zu tun wir
haben mehr Chinesen zu tun haben die
viel größer als wir die Teilen manche
Dinge nicht die bei uns im Grundgesetz
stehen die sind aber trotzdem in
Teilbereichen für uns hilfreich weil sie
einfach aufnehmen könnten deswegen
beurteil ich das sehr viel positive auch
als sie das ist für mich der Punkt
es gibt doch am Ende nur zwei
Möglichkeiten wenn ich das richtig
verstehe die eine ist zu sagen wir
zwingen in militärischen
Verhandlungstisch das ist die Haltung
mehr Waffen mehr offensivere Waffen
solche die den stärker zurückdrängen
oder aber die andere Variante dieser
sagt wir müssen der Ukraine helfen der
Bevölkerung insbesondere deswegen
Flughafen und sowas alles tun aber alle
diplomatischen Möglichkeiten nutzen
gerade mit Einfluss auf andere
Widerspruch ich glaube
unterschätzen den eigenen denn ähm
glaube ich nicht aber ich stelle nur auf
Facebook nicht unterstellen dass sie das
nicht stimmt gar nicht im Gegenteil das
finde er wird ja keine sehr täte zu
wenig ist noch kein Land zu
Unterstützung im Video Ukraine in den
letzten Jahrzehnten zu Recht und ich
teile das ja auch sie sagen wir brauchen
Friedensverhandlungen und so die kommen
natürlich nicht von heute auf morgen
sondern da wird viel hinter
verschlossenen amerikanische Präsidenten
der weiß auch dass ein Wahlkampf kommt
der ist da auch tätig gott sei Dank ist
er das ich bin nur nicht so skept und
was ich eben erleben ist
es gibt ja eigentlich in Deutschland nur
die AFD und die Wagenknecht Leute die
bestreiten dass der Aggressor ist
ansonsten gibt es den Streit über die
Frage
militärlogik ja oder nein ist die
Toleranz für die andere Position nicht
besonders ausgeprägt ist sondern man
wird immer der Putin narrative
verdächtig wenn man nicht glaubt das
kann militärischer
Problems der deutschen Debatte ja ich
habe ihn das schon mehrfach gesagt dass
sie ihre Haltung sehr respektiere man
kann die auch haben nur die Frage nach
der Lösung ist die große Frage und die
Frage wie wir aus dieser Gewaltspirale
in der wir da jetzt festsetzen mit mit
mit einem bis an die Zähne bewaffneten
Land und ich rede jetzt nicht von
Russland ich rede von der Ukraine mitten
in Europa wie kommen wir da raus darüber
können wir vielleicht gleich noch mal
nachdenken über die die ähm über das
Szenario oder sich daraus ergibt an an
Sie die Frage käsewetter sie sagen das
Misstrauen aus dem Kanzleramt trifft die
Ukraine zu tiefsten ja wie ist das
gemeint ja also das zunächst noch mal
ich bin nicht ganz mit ihnen der Meinung
dass Russland seine Ziele nicht erreicht
Russland brüstet sich 740.000 Kinder
entführt zu haben das Rote Kreuz spricht
von etwa 200.000 und die Ukraine sagt
sie können nachweisen das ist über
20.000 oder um die 20.000 Kinder waren
und sie haben erst 378 zurück das ist
das demografische Problem dass sie lösen
wollen indem eben 100.000
militärisch nicht lösen können sondern
dazu brauchen wir internationale
Gerichtsbarkeit aber was jetzt ihren
Punkt angeht Misstrauen gegenüber
Misstrauen ich spreche mal ganz bewusst
die Sprachen ist an #ner
Großbritannien und Frankreich an die
dieses Kalb seltsamer Name und Sturm
shadows geliefert haben mit klaren
Verträgen die haben zwei Varianten sie
haben eine Variante mit 400 km und eine
mit 280 und sie haben der Ukraine diese
geliefer sind das sind Raketen die sehr
genau treffen und über 280 km fliegen
und haben sie den Vertrag ausgehandelt
und die Ukraine müssen alle Bedingungen
erfüllen also das Vertrauen ist in dem
Vertrag gegossen die Amerikaner haben
was uns Deutschen sehr schwer fällt aber
weil wir eben nicht ausreichend Munition
geliefert haben diese clustermunition
geliefert das sind flächenfeuerwaffen
deren Minen nach einiger Zeit zerlegen
aber eben nicht alle und gefährlich sind
für die Zivilbevölkerung da haben sie
fünf Bedingungen an die Ukraine gestellt
ich habe mir das im Außenministerium mit
Industrieministerium in dem
verteilungsministerium angehört und mit
diesen fünf Bedingungen müssen die
Ukrainer jeden Tag berichten also wie
die Waffen eingesetzt werden und dann
sagen sie Mensch die Amerikaner
vertrauen uns die Franzosen und die
Briten warum können wir nicht einen
solchen Vertrag auch über Taurus mit dem
deutschen Kanzleramt abschließen da
lässt sich über Reichweiten reden da
lässt sich aber auch über die
Einsatzgebiete reden die haben nur 500
km aus dem ganz einfachen Grund
Reichweite weil die deutsche Luftwaffe
keine Luft Überlegenheit hat und
deswegen lieber abstandswaffen auf große
Entfernung einsetzt und der zweite Grund
warum die 500 km reichen ist weil die
Deutschen Respekt vor Staudämmen
Krankenhäusern Kernkraftwerken haben so
können die umflogen werden und der
richtige Aspekt ist auch noch das bisher
die Ukraine keine aus westlicher
Unterstützung stammenden Waffen auf
russischem Boden eingesetzt haben und
mit diesen Bedingungen glaube ich könnte
das Kanzleramt viel Boden gut machen mir
geht es nicht darum eine Grundsatzkritik
am Kanzleramt zu machen sondern zu
verweisen dass unsere britischen und
französischen Partner und die Amerikaner
ihre Bedingungen entstehen darf ich mal
an den an den ehemaligen bundeswehrmann
oder ich käsewetter die Frage stellen
wenn es offenbar diese sehr zynischen
Statistiken gibt die nachweisen wollen
sozusagen was diese Zögerlichkeit diese
deutsche Zögerlichkeit in der Ukraine
schon ein Todesopfern gekostet hat ich
frage mich wer macht solche Statistiken
wie kommen die Zustande sie sagten das
gerade
Artikel Journalisten Kollegen von ihnen
das geschrieben und hat vorgeworfen
habe ich gesagt ich glaube man muss da
gegenhalten was wir zum Beispiel durch
Flugabwehr Leben retten und im Übrigen
in der gleichen in der gleichen Zeitung
einen Artikel darüber das ist inzwischen
üblich geworden sei die Drohnen Opfer
wechselseitig auf Video zu dokumentieren
sowohl die Ukraine als an die Russen
machen das als soll das schon
multimedia-spektakel sozusagen das heißt
die Verrohung die der Krieg mit sich
bringt nimmt auch zu aber ich glaube für
eine solche Untersuchung gibt es keine
Parameter deswegen würde ich das also
im November sprechen
weil ich da von einer Hilfsorganisation
zurückkam die sich um Witwen und weisen
kümmert von ja der Ehepartner nichts
übrig geblieben ist weil sie in alten
sowjetischen Modellen nicht überlebt
haben und habe gesagt wir sollten damals
ging so Mörder und Leopard liefern wir
machen uns mit schuldig dass so wenige
überleben wenn die Treffer haben und wir
wissen es sind um die 60 westliche Kampf
und Schützenpanzer zerstört worden von
Russland das aber alle überlebt haben
die da drin waren was bei den anderen
Systemen nicht der Fall ist also es geht
auch nicht gegen die Lieferung
westlicher Waffen es geht darum weil uns
in den 70er Jahren das Leben der eigenen
Soldaten etwas wert war und wichtig war
dass wir eben teurere Waffensysteme
hatten die aber ein Überleben garantiert
haben in der Bundeskanzler hat das sehr
ernst zur Kenntnis genommen und ich
unterstelle ihm auch nicht
unernsthaftigkeit aber ich glaube dass
in unserem Land etwas mehr Orientierung
und Mut gegenüber der Bevölkerung dazu
gehört ich weiß sind über 100
Wahlkreisen bei Kollegen und Kollegen
eingeladen übrigens auch in der neuen
Ländern auch in Sachsen und danach hätte
ich jetzt das nächste Mal gefragt
und dort sagen sagen die Leute auch oh
diese Argumente haben wir noch nicht
gehört danke sie müssen Sie nicht teilen
aber ich glaube etwas mehr Mut auch aus
dem Kanzleramt wie ist die
Außenministerin hat wie es sogar
Finanzminister Lindner hat oder Markus
Faber oder Michael Roth den ich sehr
schätze den wir beide sehr schätzen weil
unsere Ausschussvorsitzender ist sollten
wir tun
muss entscheiden
also erstens meiner Erfahrung ist von
Flensburg bis zum Bodensee von dem
Saarland bis Sachsen egal wo ich bin
dass ich unglaublich viel Zustimmung
höre mehr als zu jedem anderen Thema in
den letzten Jahren zu dem was der
Bundeskanzler tut deutlich mehr die
Leute sind umso mehr es ist wirklich so
nein es ist wirklich so
kommen
Munition falsch unabhängig von den
Bedingungen die daran geknüpft sind die
Deutschen haben sich so recht geächtet
das sind und drittens der Punkt ist ja
nicht die Frage von Misstrauen sondern
der Punkt ist die Frage von
Verantwortung der Bundeskanzler haftet
ja nicht nur dafür mit seiner
politischen verantwortlich auch nicht
abgeben kann dass wir die Ukraine so gut
wie können unterstützen das tun wir wie
ich finde deutlich mehr als behauptet
wird sondern auch dass der kriegst dich
nicht ausweide dass sie nicht
Kriegsteilnehmer werden
schließt doch Verträge aber diese diese
Verantwortung nimmt ihn niemand hat man
kann sich auch täuschen
das glaube ich auch aber ehrlich gesagt
die nimmt dem niemand ab deswegen glaube
ich auch es ist leichter aus der
Opposition zu fordern liefert als der
Mann am Ende entscheiden muss
jetzt hat er natürlich wir sehen hier
mit Augenklappe jetzt hat er keine
Augenklappe mehr seit heute mir
aufgefallen aber
er ist natürlich der der ein Versprechen
abgegeben hat ein Zeitenwende
versprechen 2 % nachvollziehen Erfüllung
findet
das sozusagen die wenn wir uns den
Haushalt angucken wenn wir das
Sondervermögen angucken wenn wir die
Mittelverwendung angucken das meinte ich
damit das scheint sowas hoffen wir doch
alle dass der Krieg möglichst schnell
aufhört denn diese sozusagen die Zeiten
Wände in Geld ausgedrückt findet nicht
so statt wie versprochen
gegeben hat in einer Bedrohungssituation
über die wir uns glaube ich alle einig
sind dass man Taurus Flughafen
möglicherweise in Absprachen mit den USA
die zwar Streumunition liefern aber sich
bei der Frage der marschflow-körper ja
auch mich also an die Spitze der
Bewegung stellen dass man das abspricht
und möglicherweise besonders wächst weil
auf einmal deutsche Marschflugkörper
doch in hinter Russlands Grenzen dann
kann man
diese Wetter mit Michael Kretschmann
darauf spielen sie gerade an genau der
sächsische Ministerpräsident nicht genau
das ist der einzige die sind
eine Bevölkerung gesagt das wollen wir
nicht aber das ist genau der Punkt ich
verweise einfach auf den
Ministerpräsidenten von Sachsen-Anhalt
der eine ganz klare Haltung hat der in
der Mitte 36 % geholt hat 21 der auch
eine sehr klare Haltung heute hat und
Michael Kretschmer hat mir und das muss
ich sehr hoch einschätzen auch sehr hoch
hoch bewerten hat mir ermöglicht mit
seinen CDU Landtagsabgeordneten mit
seinen Kreisvorsitzenden mit über 240
man darf Pflegerinnen und Mandatsträgern
aus Sachsen zu sprechen und die teilen
diese Auffassung nicht um Michael
Kretschmer sagt auch sehr deutlich er
ist da in einer Minderheit aber das ist
seine Einschätzung die wird von der CDU
Sachsen nicht geteilt ich habe Respekt
davor aber weil er sie so explizit
geäußert hat obwohl wir uns über Monate
immer wieder ausgetauscht haben wir
mischen uns nicht in die Sächsische
Innenpolitik eher nicht in die
Bundespolitik haben wir habe ich mich da
auch sehr klar geäußert sie haben
geschrieben
Millionen Fehler bekommen werden der
entscheidende Punkt ist wenn die Ukraine
nicht die ausreichend Unterstützung
bekommt wir diskutieren ja viel zu
technisch geht um es zu abstrakte geht
immer nur um Militär die Frage ist was
macht denn dieser Krieg die Entführungen
da sehen wir uns ja eigentlich die
Entführung was macht das mit den
Familien jede Familie hat Opfer und wenn
Sie sehen dass sie Land für Frieden
geben müssen oder dass die Unterstützung
sie ermüdet und sie nicht mehr mal mehr
die Durchbrüche die sie mit viel Opfern
erreicht haben mit ordentlich Waffen und
einem weiteren Angriff zum Beispiel zum
Abschn während der Krim erzielen können
sowie im letzten Jahr der Gegenangriff
ja auch verhungert ist dann werden die
Ukrainer und Ukrainer das ist mein
Eindruck aus den letzten Besuchen wenn
sie das Land verlassen sie wollen ganz
kurz den Satz noch sie wollen nicht
unter russischem Joch Leben und sie
wollen auch nicht unter einem
diktatfrieden leben sie wollen ihr Land
in den Grenzen von 91 wieder haben und
jetzt kommt unser Punkt wenn wir die
Ukraine hängen lassen dann kommen
irgendwelche Führungen dran die uns
vielleicht gar nicht gefallen und
deswegen sollten wir hier sehr
intensiver sagen sie dürfen sofort ich
habe nur eine sozusagen
das war letzten Herbst so weil dieser
Gegend Offensive die ist einfach
verhungert das heißt wir erleben jetzt
alle Toilette wir leben das gleich
was was ist da passiert
also das Entscheidende ist dass die
Ukrainer nicht die Luft Überlegenheit
haben die sie brauchen weder
Kampfhubschrauber noch Flugzeuge und
Russland weite Teile des Gebietes 30%
des Landes vermiet hat kann man sich
vorstellen sie stellen sich ein
Fußballplatz vor nur ein bisschen
hügeliger und auf jedem Quadratmeter
liegen zwei drei vier Minen die finden
Sie nicht weil die so klein sind oder
weil sie vergraben sind und dann gehen
die mit Nadeln gewesen das sind bis zu
39 40 verschiedene Typen ja von Minen im
Einsatz unter anderem Minen die wenn man
drauf tritt hoch springen und dann in
der Luft existieren kann ich vom Balkan
Krieg und all diese Mittel werden dort
eingesetzt und die ukrainischen Soldaten
arbeiten sich auf allen vieren vor mit
bestimmten Nadeln versuchen Sie
rauszuarbeiten dann ziehen sich zurück
dann werden die gesprengt und dann geht
es weiter und das machen sie ohne Luft
Überlegenheit der diese clustermunition
jeder eingesetzt werden soll dient dazu
diese Minenfelder zu springen damit sie
mit gepanzerten Fahrzeugen durchfahren
können das ist der Grund warum man diese
in Deutschland geächtete in Russland und
keine nicht geächtete Munition verwendet
und dieses sogenannte streumunternehmen
ist dass die Ukraine zu wenig Mittel hat
dadurch zu kommen deswegen wäre jetzt
eben hilfreich gewesen wenn wir im
letzten Jahr tatsächlich den Auftrag an
die Industrie gegeben hätten
entsprechend Munition zu produzieren kam
von Schützenpanzer zu produzieren die
Polen haben 100 Panzer nachbestellt die
Deutschen die gelieferten 18 das dauert
natürlich und die Gefahr ist eben dass
die ukrainischen Soldaten ganz kurz die
Verhältnisse die Polen haben 100 Panzer
bestimmt wie 18 sind also die Polen
haben etwas mehr als 100 Panzer
geliefert insgesamt verschiedene Arten
haben dafür 100 Leopard nach bestellt
die Deutschen haben 18 Leopard 2
geliefert und haben 18 nachbestellt sie
haben auch Leopard 1 geliefert aber das
ist viel zu technisch es ist sehr wenig
und die Ukraine hat nicht mehr das
Personal ich habe mit traumatisierten
Soldaten gesprochen die sind 10 Monate
an der Front kommen für zwei Wochen nach
Hause treffen drei Tage die Familien
sind acht Tage im Trauma Behandlung um
die Bilder einigermaßen zu bewältigen
irgendwann müde die können nicht mehr
das wollte ich sie gerade fragen einmal
die sozusagen aus erster Hand mal der
Perspektivwechsel die Ukraine die
ukrainische Gesellschaft wollen die das
wollen die weiter kämpfen oder gibt es
dieser Tage mit einem Kollegen
gesprochen der sagte naja weißt du für
mich ist ehrlich gesagt auch die Frage
nach dem ganz brutalen und auch
zynischen Bevölkerungsaustausch ne in
der aus der Ukraine der da teilweise
stattgefunden hat mit Blick auf eine
Krimi die ohnehin sehr russisch immer
schon war auch historisch
gibt es überhaupt den Wunsch dieser
Leute noch sozusagen von der Ukraine
befreit zu werden oder sagen die absolut
es geht um 5 Millionen Menschen die die
dort nicht leben wollen sind längst
gegangen und
Meinungsumfragen selbst auf der Krim
vor der Besetzung über 60 Prozent aber
in der Ostukraine über 80 Prozent der
Bevölkerung die sagen wir wollen
weiterkämpfen wir wollen nicht aufgeben
und in der Gesamtbevölkerung sind es
tatsächlich über 90 Prozent und ist das
natürlich in tschernowitz oder im
kaiserlichen
Ukraine etwas anders aber auch dort
schlagen Granaten ein dort werden
Flughäfen und Kindergärten zerstört aber
der und das ist das ich war bei
meinungsforschungsinstitution hätten
eigentlich nur eine deutliche ganz
ehrlich also haben wir eben auch
gesprochen
ich war bei Meinungsforschungsinstituten
unterschiedliche Art und die haben alle
Zahlen zwischen 80 und 93% Unterstützung
tatsächlich repräsentativ verstehen ich
muss ganz ehrlich sagen sie sagen im
Wesentlichen der Ukraine der schlecht
wir müssen liefern was wir können
habt euch nicht so redet gefälligst mit
den Leuten so dass ihr mehr dafür kriegt
und das mit der Bevölkerung kann man
schon hinkriegen wenn man nur genug Mut
hat so haben sie ja von Muttern
wenn der Frage wie man den Krieg beenden
kann und ich sage Ihnen die deutschen
Bevölkerung die Haltung der deutschen
Bevölkerung ist zum Teil davon geprägt
dass die Eltern auch sehr genau wissen
was der Krieg mit ihren Eltern gemacht
hat dass sie das als Kinder entweder
erlebt haben dass die aus tiefer
Überzeugung sagen wir wollen nicht in
den Krieg hineingezogen werden dass die
eben nicht überzeugt werden wir müssen
nur genügend auf sie einreden dann
werden die auch akzeptieren dass wir
viel mehr Militär Ausgaben brauchen das
mag auch noch viele Jahre gehen und was
sie auch übersehen finde ich wenn sie
jetzt so beschreiben das wiederholt sich
alles vom letzten Jahr die die für immer
härtere Waffen plädiert haben sich auch
getäuscht in ihren einschätzen die
kriegt sie nein haben sich verändert da
jedesmal das geht wenn wir das nochmal
machen dann funktioniert das sondern
dieses und dann wurde argumentiert der
putin ist sehr schlecht mit dem mit dem
Aufstand in der Nacht viele dieser
Einschätzung sind falsch gewesen und ich
sage nur dieser Einschätzung sind falsch
gewesen und ich sage Ihnen nur ich bin
fest davon überzeugt dass das die
kritisieren genau das was sie
kritisieren nämlich dass der
Bundeskanzler sehr genau wirkt was er
tut dass wir uns sehr genau mit den
amerikanten abstimmen ist ja eben auch
andere Dinge miteinander verfolgen die
überwältigende Zustimmung unserer
Bevölkerung hat und da geht es nicht um
Mut und die Leute von sowas anderen zu
überzeugen sondern da geht es darum auch
zu verhindern dass die AFD noch mehr
Prozent gekriegt weil man
falsch
ihre kernannahme ist falsch die
kernannahme heißt dass unsere
Bevölkerung nicht Kriegs Partei werden
will wir sind aber Kriegsziele und es
fehlt dass der Kanzler deutlich macht
dass in der hybriden
informationsverfälschung in den Fake
News dass hier die Amerikaner ein
Wirtschaftskrieg führen und wir sein die
Instrumente und vieles mehr was sie
alles tun die Orientierung
also wenn sie sagen man muss die
Bevölkerung man muss sagen machen
[Musik]
man kann es nachdenklichen Haltung
nennen aber
also der der eigene Kanzler sehr sehr
klar und der hat auch heute noch mal
gesagt ein Frieden ohne ja das ist alles
freiheit ist das ist alles richtig aber
es gibt eine Alternative zu dem Kurs zu
sagen wir müssen nur genügend Waffen
liefern die könnte nämlich heißen wir
müssen die Bevölkerung schützen indem
wir zum Beispiel modernste
luftabwehrtechnik liefern das tun wir
auch sehr Text und ansonsten aber viele
Dinge tun für die der Kanzler kritisiert
wird erst kritisiert man als seiner
China gegangen ist er redet mit dem
Brasilianern die viele unser Werte nicht
teilen die wir aber trotzdem brauchen
versucht Präsident Putin gerade mehr
oder Männer eingeladen haben
meine Eindruck ist der Kanzler hat sich
von ein paar Telefonaten mit Putin
einschüchtern lassen
wir haben ja eine sehr spannende
Entwicklung gehabt eine sagenhafte
Zeitenwende Rede
aber damals waren viele der Auffassung
die SPD hat sich sicher da gewandelt das
muss man ja sagen das war der der
notwendige Teil der Zeitenwende
aber der entscheidende Punkt der Zeiten
wenn der Rede war die große Sorge dass
Russland innerhalb weniger Wochen die
Ukraine einnimmt und dann an der Grenze
zu Moldau und Polen steht das war der
eigentliche grundzeitenwende zwei
Prozent hier sofort im letzten Jahr 2%
sofort und die und 100 Milliarden damit
verrechnet aber wir haben wieder im
letzten Jahr noch in diesem Jahr noch im
nächsten Jahr die zwei Prozent muss man
ganz ehrlich so sagen
das ist der eine Aspekt und der andere
Aspekt ist dass der Kanzler im Juni
letzten Jahres im Auswärtigen Ausschuss
des Bundestages auf die Fragen das wurde
dann Twitter öffentlich damals ist das
noch so nicht X auf die Fragen von
Kollegen erndel und mir gesagt hat die
Lieferung von Marder sei eine furchtbare
Eskalation und das ist sicherlich nicht
eindeutig der Bundesregierung und es ist
eben immer wieder von Putins Seite
gesagt worden wenn Schweden und Finnland
Ukraine eintreten ist das denn nuklearf
Fall wenn Bulgarien weiter Waffen und
Munition liefert werden wir dort
einschreiten wenn die Bundesrepublik
Deutschland Kampfpanzer liefert ist das
eine furchtbare Eskalation das heißt das
ist diese selbstabschreckung diese Angst
man hat mehr Angst vor Putin dem man auf
der anderen Seite unterstellt dass er ja
irgendwo auch berechenbar sei als dass
man die Ukraine richtig unterstützt
nein aber der Bundeskanzler hat keine
Kanzlerin
über kampfpanzerlieferung gar nicht mit
diskutieren elf Länder und jetzt haben
wir diese Taurus debat das heißt also
die Frage ist will er sich immer treiben
lassen
Verantwortung kommen und wenn sie sagen
quatsch ich muss sagen Schafe Worte wo
ist eigentlich ihre Veränderung bei der
Zeiten Wände der ihr Parteivorsitzender
März hat letztes Jahr gesagt boykottiert
das russische Gast hätten wir das
gemacht hätten wir katastrophale
Zusammenbrüche gab
industigerweise sie haben gesagt dass
der Eintrag auf die Pipeline war als
wenn sie Sprengstoffexperte werden
müssen Unterschied
anders aber ich bewundere ihre selbst
Gewissheit was sie alles wissen ich weiß
vieles nicht ich kann nur sagen die
anderen sollten nicht schief gehen und
den Bundeskanzler sollten Sie nicht
unterstellen dass er Angst vor Putin hat
ganz im Gegenteil ja stimmt sich mit dem
amerikanischen versenden ab und das
steht nur ein besonderes sondern
Vernunft die Besonnenheit des Kanzlers
ist oft wirkt oft wie unterlassene Hilfe
Leistung und ich hätte mir sehr
gewünscht dass die Bundeskanzler im
Bundestag im Bundestag sich nicht dazu
verleiten ist zu sagen dass die
Lieferung von Schützenpanzern eine
furchtbare Eskalation denn die
Eskalation geht von Russland aus und
nicht von der Ukraine hier müssen wir
schon die Kleiderordnung
das liefert dann muss man auch das
liefern das finde ich
ja aber die Entscheidung muss doch
jemals neu getroffen werden und deswegen
kein Dominoeffekt
entscheiden
doch immer wieder Thema sie sagen die
die Sprengung der Pipelines das war eine
Falle Flecken selber und haben es lassen
es jetzt aussehen als wären Ukrainer
gewesen so ist es hochinteressant wie
wie diese Diskussion läuft in der
Bundesrepublik Deutschland wird dieselbe
Indizienkette in die Ukraine gelegt wie
sie ich war in Finnland ich war in in
Dänemark und in einem anderen Land und
habe auch mit den nachrichtendienstchefs
gesprochen und die legen dieselbe
Indizienkette an und einer sagte mir
allroads lead Thomas kau alle Wege
führen
und das ist naja gut wird ja nicht
falsch
sondern das Entscheidende ist dass die
Indizienkette
noch nicht endgültig aufgeklärt ist und
ich wäre mich dagegen dass einfach
gesagt wird es führt in die Ukraine nein
wir haben doch keine endgültige doch das
war der Spiegel und deswegen deutlich
Hinweisen
auch dass sie sich äußern als ob sie es
wissen ich kann nur sagen Gott sei Dank
ist im Land wie Deutschland gibt
Ermittlungsbehörden die neutral
was man gerne hätte hätte
es geht darum dass die Ermittlungen dass
die Bundesregierung in der strategischen
Kommunikation nichts dagegen unternimmt
dass die Art und Weise wie die
Enthüllungen laufen ausgerechnet
eindeutig in Richtung Ukraine laufen die
eine Anweisung die eine die eine
hervorragende Vorbereitung mit falschen
Informationen verbreite Information
dass die Indizienkette nicht
abschließend in die Ukraine nicht
abschließen nach Russland führt das
einzige was klar ist das ist nicht nach
Amerika führt denn die haben sehr
geschickt die Wege in Richtung Europa
gelingt ganz deutlich festhalten
öffentlich berichtet ein ukrainischen
Pass richtig aber sie hat die russische
Staatsbürgerschaft sie lebte auf der
Krim sie ist jetzt in krasnoda und
bewegt sich frei in Russland sehr mutig
und es gibt noch kein Ergebnis dieser
eine Punkt ja gerade so ein bisschen
untergeht sie sagten gerade da muss man
schon dafür sorgen dass sozusagen die
richtigen Dinge dann das nicht der
Öffentlichkeit erreicht erreichen oder
wie war das gemeint also ein deutscher
Bundeskanzler oder auch ein deutscher
weil sie in deutscher Minister
Verteidigungsminister kann doch nicht
den Staatsanwalt anweisen und sagen du
bitte mal dafür dass Sie
Informationen
ich wollte folgendes sagen dass der
Eindruck entsteht dass die
Bundesregierung sich überhaupt nicht
äußert und dass sie in der Art und Weise
wie bestimmte Medien darüber berichten
dass weder widersprochen noch geklärt
wird und in der Öffentlichkeit der
Eindruck entsteht dass man
unwidersprochen hinnimmt nächstes Jahr
in die Ukraine führt wenn ich eine
Operation mache muss ich doch sehr
deutlich sagen dass in Russland ein
früherer kgb-chef führt dass er die
Kirchen gleichgeschaltet hat dass die
Art und Weise wie dieses Schiff diese
diese diese Jolle fährt überhaupt nicht
in der Öffentlichkeit debattiert wird
dass davor mehreren
sich doch regelmäßig sagen der Punkt
gewesen es ich kann nur sagen die
Behauptung seine verspricht nahezu
nichts und es sind amerikanische Medien
in den USA die dort auch nicht
reglementiert werden das sind deutsche
Journalisten wieder essen deutsche
Ermittlungsbehörden die haben mehrmals
nach gibt es irgendeinen die verfolgt
gibt es nicht es gibt
richtig rein die großen waren das nicht
und wir werden weil es einfacher ist
wenn das so wäre aber sich hinzustellen
wie sie und zu sagen das waren die die
irgendwie raus das ist nun eine
Regierung in einem Fall der nicht
abgeschlossen
zu halten ist mir wichtiger als das
immer behauptet wird
unsere Gesellschaft okay